and breaking news tonight dr jesus
jarrow will return to his duties as
superintendent of the clark county
school district on monday we thank you
for joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez dr jarrah
releasing a statement tonight indicating
he reached an agreement with the
majority of the board on the best path
forward now that statement went on to
say as my team continued to lead our
district the fifth largest in america
through devastating pandemic related
learning disruptions and challenges for
our students mental health there were
too many adult-centered distractions
that cause instability starting on
monday in this critical moment we're
going to continue working day and night
to make sure that we re-center our focus
on our student safety mental health and
unfinished learning these are our core
priorities this is the first time we've
heard from dr jarrah since the board
voted to fire him at the end of october
then trustees threw out their vote to
terminate his contract trustees also
releasing a statement tonight that reads
in part while the first step of this
process is completed we will continue
striving for a more collaborative
respectful and supportive board and
superintendent relationship